ce que vous pourriez basculer cyril
hanouna la saison prochaine sur canal+
en access puisqu'on sait que l'info du
vrai de yves calvi ne sera plus là la
saison prochaine
c'est ce qu'a laissé entendre gérald
brice viret le patron des antennes et
des programmes de canal alors pour la
rentrée de canal rien n'est fait rien
n'est décidé tout est ouvert donc oui ça
fait partie des ddd chose envisagée au
sein du groupe pendant on en parle vous
savez j'aime cyril est un génie de la
télévision
cyril c'est quelqu'un qui s'implique
beaucoup plus qu'on imagine dans la vie
de tous les jours des mails je voulais
en même temps et on a beaucoup de
projets avec cyril à la rentrée pour ses
8 après bah moi de toute façon puisque
j'ai aussi cette casquette je
travaillerai avec cyril avec plaisir sur
canal tout est ouvert rien n'est tranché
ce qu'ils sont
[Applaudissements]
arrêté et taisez vous pourquoi 10 à sa
merci merci à eric tu te fous de ma
gueule non alors on a vu que franck
c'est parce que c'est un ami c'est pour
ça il sait que je laime le président de
ces 8es également faut savoir que francs
capitaux est également directeur des
programmes et de canal+ canal+ fait
partie du groupe sémites canal+ c'est le
même groupe juste petit tour de table
est ce que pour vous vous pensez que
franck appelé tôt a dans la tête que je
bifurque sur quade a pu s'en donner
votre avis ah bon alors là c'est facile
quoi ils perdent un éventuel penser oui
évidemment oui serait très très fort de
le faire d'abord le seul problème s'est
dépouillé une chaîne pour valoriser
notre corps a besoin
en clair de remonter les audiences en
clair de canal ce serait une
merveilleuse idée vous avez votre public
vous allez je sais pas comment vous
allez faire peut-être constituer une
équipe une nouvelle équipe pourquoi pas
où nous pas deux ou trois comme comme
moi et
[Rires]
non c'est génial canal+ c'est toujours
c'est toujours ça reste toujours un rêve
canal plus simple moi je pense pas qu'il
puisse penser ça parce que ce serait une
erreur pour moi et on a une émission qui
est très installé depuis plus de dix ans
qui marche très bien et je trouve ça
dangereux de la mettre sur une autre
chaîne trahissent il y aura dix mois je
pense qu'on peut vous suivre n'importe
où une sorte de nuage en soi des
modernes avec un ep mp btp associés moi
je trouve ce serait très bonne atp plus
oui bah je pense que économiquement ce
serait intéressant pour le groupe ce
serait je pense une bonne façon de gérer
le budget qu'il faut gérer et je pense
qu'effectivement canal+ ou autre chose
vous avez un public donc poussé sur
canal + sur france 2 sur france 3 sur
france 5 6 honnêtement ça ne changerait
pas grand chose après je trouve que
l'image canal plus et c'est très chic
c'est très beau et moi je trouve que
c'est un bon témoin chic non mais je dis
pas ça mais bon on convient que gallas
et ses cannes à puce et près de l'homme
sans c'est dans cette ligne homme au
sahara mais avant c'était france cas de
votre sens du matin après et et s'est
vite votre sens inné du but alors vous
votre sang et or s'était pas vu sa mort
c'est comment comment faire avec sur une
chaîne où le film commence toujours à
21h avec vous ça c'est un problème assez
bas alors regardez regarderai les
programmes de canal+ le film ne démarre
jamais parfois 21h04 menthe et ne ratez
norvège ou le dicta faut regarder
puisque je me suis permis de regarder
moi aussi je m'intéresse à la planète
je suis bien c'est une émission médias
c'est pas que de la danse sur canal
gabon
mais je vais vous dire je vais tous vous
sinon je te paierai sarkozy de vous dire
non alors aujourd'hui sachez le tout est
ouvert
maintenant et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs très possible qu'on va
sur ses 8 et où ces chats ne sait pas ce
qui peut se passer voilà le sait le même
groupe
six mois ça dépend de la direction si la
direction de canal+ et la direction du
groupe me dit on a besoin de toi sur
canal+ bien entendu je ferai ce qu'ils
me disent qu'ils me diront de fer et
sachez le quoi qu'il arrive on sera en
clair ça veut dire que même si un jour
on va sur un bus sera en clair c'est à
dire que c'est pareil c'est juste au
lieu d'être sur l'a8 sera sur la quatre
voies la saison mais si vous avez envie
parce que j'ai envie de faire oui j'ai
juste envie de vivre
moi j'ai juste envie de dire
patrick patrick jolly et comme l'a dit
franck happi rien à faire soyez soyez
sincère je vous les auriez s'ils ont
envie de vivre
[Rires]
je sais tu veux je veux mettre la cbc
toi je vais mettre la matinée c'est de
finir alors vas-y à la base'' ma maison
tu l'as fait
interroge raison peut-être peut-être
peut-être que nous irons sur canalplus
fr
sinon nous resterons là et vous j'ai
juste envie de vivre à l'heure qu'il est
on ne sait pas du tout vous voulez vous
avez oublié oui moi combien d'émissions
marche très très bien
c'est sur ces 8 c'est vrai que c'est
franchement on fait des scores
incroyables et les gens se font une
envie de prendre l'air mais messi si je
ne changera pas fondamentalement les
missions de combat sur une autre chaîne
non il y aura toujours des témoins du
jour le débat et voilà on rigolera
toujours mais c'est passé voilà on aime
et scénique je vous le dis c'est lui le
patron du groupe qui décidera voilà je
vous dirais que non rien que décide le
patron maxime saada francs capitaux ces
eaux qui décidera bon ça c'est vraiment
moi j'essaie d'orienter rail que là et
je suis pas moi c'est toi qu'est ce tu
sors toi moi je n'en avais que ce soit
tu sautes jeu dit il accuse les médias
qui la vérité j'ai plus l'impression que
tout l'intention d'y aller mais c'est
vrai que pour 26 et paraît bien sûr ces
huit ans sur un truc pareil c'est le
même groupe voilà c'est pareil c'est
franchement ccfa la syrie le principal
c'est que tu y restes d'un amour est
pour l'instant ses valeurs sa maison
pour continuer à s'amuser et voilà